Beth starts off this hour in Fort
Collins Colorado hi Beth how are you
Dave I'm great great to talk to you
today how are you better than I deserve
what's up so my husband and I have been
following your plans for a while now and
we're just finishing up with baby steps
tree and things are going great for us
however I'm calling today because my
mother-in-law and my brother-in-law are
struggling financially and we're trying
to help them get on board with the Dave
plan and I'm worried that if they don't
get a better handle on their finances
and my husband and I are going to have
to step in help support them and we
already have a full plate with three
young kids and so just wondering are
giving any advice on how to help them
help themselves
how old is your mother-in-law she's 71
and what does your brother-in-law have
to do with her does he live with her so
yes she's allowed him to live with her
in apartment my father-in-law passed
away about 11 years ago it's wrong new
brother-in-law he's kind of a deadbeat
poor thing yeah he's just not there's
another lot going on with him and she's
kept the job for the last year but he's
just you know so far in debt and he need
to struggle the day-to-day he's had some
drug issues in the past as well if you
give redbull to a lazy person you've
just got a lazy person exactly yeah so
he's kind of draining my mother-in-law
what little income she has she has
nothing saved at all yeah how is her
health her health is okay she's still
working she's a CNA but like old-old is
the brother-in-law druggie lazy guy he's
31 mm well number one I think you and
your husband need to have some
discussions about what you are willing
to do and for whom you're willing to do
it I have pretty strong opinions about
that as you might get
and that would be a 71 year old widow
lady that is my mom I'm gonna do a lot
detect a care of her I'm doing 0 for
this other guy right he's a parasite
okay and really a lot serious hard times
might be good for him and you know the
only way I'm doing anything for him is
if he's on a whole lot better track than
he's on right now like um you know he's
actually working all the time he's
drug-free he's you know and so on he's
got he's you know whole different animal
starts to evolve then has so far so I'm
worried I have to take care of him later
it's not a statement I'm gonna make I
might be in a position that I'm wealthy
enough that I choose to help him if he
is doing some things that are taking him
in a positive direction
I'm not going to finance his bad
behavior like his mommy did mm-hmm
because everyone's patted his little
hand his whole life and said he'd get
better sweetie it ain't gonna get better
mm-hmm
okay because he's a bum until he stops
bum stuff then he's gonna be there now
first and I can separate the two of
these as far as who I'm willing to help
and what I'm willing to help so I doubt
that you're probably going to talk mom
into behaving with money while she's
trying to take care of and be
codependent with this parasite okay I
doubt you're probably gonna have much
issue there you know progress there as
long as that relationship stays in that
toxic form that it's in it's not good
it's not good it's not good for him
because he's not getting better he's not
addressing his character issues it's not
good for her because he's sucking the
bone marrow out of her life right you
know it's just disgusting to watch it's
very difficult your husband gets mad on
one level and you get mad on a whole
nother level watching this yeah I read
your mail yeah so you need to keep your
mouth shut and step back that's his
family and let him deal with his family
and you and him talk about it behind
closed doors and then he has to say
whatever is said you can't say anything
you're just the Wicked Witch of the West
you're not allowed to say anything
you're the
in law and so can you tell yeah you can
do this
and you guys are what 35 yeah word I'm
33 my husband's 36 he's the older
brother yeah yeah yeah he's older than
you kind of taking over the the
parasites the baby yeah okay yeah that's
the one yeah I'm so sorry it's so
painful to watch people you love do
stupid stuff that destroys their own
lives it's just hard to watch it really
is and it's harsh
it just really is but you've got to you
need to establish ahead of time what
your boundaries are and what your
priorities are and what under what
circumstances you will participate if
you don't establish that ahead of time
you and your husband and go and write it
down so the two of you like have your
little family Constitution of how we're
going to deal with mom how we're going
to deal with brother if you don't it's
going to get in the moment and there'll
be a lot of emotion around it more so
for him than for you and then you're
gonna throw up your hands and go well
now we're just getting sucked into this
thing and so you need to decide ahead of
time what the boundaries are okay and if
you know ahead of time then when because
it's not a question of when they're
gonna start asking you from or if
they're gonna start asking you money
it's a question of when exactly under
what circumstances are you gonna
participate and really I'm gonna help
Mom if you can and the way you do that
is you can talk to her about it you can
get her kind of on an idea that she
might want to a budget show her some of
the stuff you're doing you can't but he
can you can be but but I really am not
gonna give you much hope she's gonna do
it cuz any progress she makes he's gonna
take okay he takes everything and and so
you know until he's out of the house and
on his own again she's gone not going to
be able to really implement a plan
because there's so much dysfunction in
the family here is what it amounts to
and so but but the last part of that is
you guys go finish your job which is
Bill well you know get yourself out of
debt like you've done you get your
college funds in place for your kids you
go build wealth and you know you're
sitting there
and we're 10 years down the road and you
guys are millionaires you got a lot
you're in a lot different position to
answer these questions then if moms 81
and juniors out of the house and now we
want to take care of mom it's kind of a
no-brainer yeah we'll take care of her
okay even though she was you know you
know in a codependent thing yeah we're
still gonna take care of it your mom you
know it's fine nothing wrong with that
and you but again you just got to be
careful that you're not financing
someone else's crazy land and that's
what you face